We looked,
we looked last time at Saint Peter's
declamatory speech in enlisted us,
and we spent a lot of time on it and we
looked at its relation to the new career.
The John Milton,
uh,
ended up assuming in the late
teen 16 in the late 1630s,
the,
this new career as a polemical,
a writer of political pros and Milton
becomes increasingly in this period.
And this is the period of the, of
the, of the English revolution.
It's what is the English revolution you
ask? Uh, whether that's a good question.
And there they're still,
um, in numerable, uh,
often competing answers to that question,
but it seems to be more or less,
this is one way of framing,
framing an answer.
It seems more or less to
be a puritan revolution.
Middleclass puritans like John Milton,
um,
find themselves upholding the authority
of Parliament over the authority of King
Charles and over the authority
of the official Church of
England. Um, that's the,
the roughest possible sketch of
what the English revolution is. Um,
we find ourselves in today's reading area.
Politica in the middle of
the English revolution,
sometimes called the puritan revolution.
It's in this period that
Milton increasingly begins
to adopt or assume Saint
Peter's a confident and
denunciatory rhetoric. Um,
he adopts it as his own.
Milton does,
and he writes a series of treatises and
supportive, uh, and this is a really,
really out there and he alienates a lot
of his natural organic base with these
actions.
But Milton writes a series of treatises
in support of the right to divorce a
divorce for reasons of in compatibility.
And he continues to assist.
The Puritan left the progressive
movement in overthrowing the hierarchical
structure of the, of the Church
of England. The bishops, uh,
also called the prelates.
Those church officials essentially
appointed by Archbishop William Lord,
who we looked at last time,
were replaced in the early 1640s by
means that the success of the Puritan
revolutionaries were replaced by
Presbyterians ministers who were chosen by
individual congregations.
And Milton was able to think of this new
form of church government as the most
reasonable form of church government
because it seemed to be the product of,
of individual choices.
It seemed to be the product of individual
decisions made by the rational church
going English public.
So by the time we get to 1644, this is
the year that area politica appears, um,
we're well into the English revolution.
And this is the, this is the year
in which we have two dominant groups
in the new revolutionary parliament.
Um, the, that you have the
conservative Anglican royalists,
they've already been ousted.
They're not,
they're no longer a central
component of the political scene.
So you have left the Presbyterians and
the independence. And at this point,
the Presbyterians are in firm control.
Now,
as with most most political groups
who suddenly find themselves.
And this is just an ancient piece
of wisdom that I'm sharing with you,
but it's something obviously that
you will have heard before. Um,
as with most political groups who suddenly
find themselves in possession of a,
of a measure of power,
the ideas and values of the Presbyterians
and who had of course started out as
radicals. Um, we're beginning to harden
into something like a new orthodoxy. Um,
with this new aggregation
of political power,
they began laboring to
suppress and laboring to stamp
out of forces that forces
that oppose them, whether those forces
were on the right or on the left.
[inaudible].
Now,
of course the presbyters had seized
control in the first place because they
disapproved of the tactics of suppression
and intervention that had been in that
had been deployed by the bishops or the,
or the prelates of the old church.
But,
but the new,
but the new Presbyterian
party soon developed its own
methods of employing state
power to control and regulate the church.
And this is just a general historical
irony that surely at some point,
um,
besets all revolutionary movements.
And it's an irony that
particularly appalled John Melton,
and it's in recognition of what we can
think of is this time honored historical
irony that that Milton rights,
that such a, such a memorable line,
a wonderful line in his sonnet
on the new Presbyterian regime.
Um, that's the, it's
the, it's the poem, uh,
of the force of the new foresters of
conscience, uh, which ends with that line.
You'll remember new presbyters are,
but old priests writ large.
The new pres bitters are, but
old priests writ large. The, the,
the revolution has essentially become
a revolution in name only priests.
These are the bishops of the old system
have changed their name to presbyters
perhaps,
and they look like revolutionaries,
but their manipulative
controlling actions haven't,
haven't essentially changed at all.
And for the Presbyterian Party in 1644,
it turns out there are in
fact a number of factions, uh,
to control and to
manipulate and to regulate.
The new Presbyterian Orthodoxy soon,
soon developed its own methods of, uh, of,
of control, of employing state power to,
to control and to regulate
and to manipulate the church.
And that's where we get
this a rousing line.
New [inaudible] is but old
priests writ large. Um,
so I, I had mentioned, um,
the various factions in parliament that
the Presbyterian party had to confront,
um, uh, the,
the independence who are to
the left of the Presbyterians.
And we can count John Milton as a,
as a supporter of the independence,
the independence,
resented the new authoritarianism of
the Presbyterians and they support it,
or at least they tolerated
a new phenomenon,
a relatively new phenomenon on
the English cultural landscape.
And this is the freedom
of the printing press.
It's a freedom that of course
parliament had pushed for. Um,
but now that they got it, uh, there,
there are some misgiving
from 1641 to 1643,
there had been an unprecedented explosion
of printing and publishing an England,
every conceivable Protestant
sect was publishing treatises of,
of theological speculation,
publishing treatises of,
of religious propaganda at
an extraordinary rate. It's,
it's really remarkable, a remarkable
things that happens, uh, in the,
in the mid century religious
propaganda of course,
and this is always the case.
Um,
unregulated religious propaganda
only reads more unregulated religious
propaganda and more religious division.
And by the end of the period,
there was an unprecedented,
unprecedented number of new
religious groups, some of whom,
uh, some of these groups born
at this moment, I'm still exist.
We still have the Quakers. Uh, we have
the baptists, but there are of course,
many groups,
uh,
thriving in the 1640s that
have absolutely faded,
um, from the religious scene,
the grantor's, the family
[inaudible], the Mughal,
Tony, Ian's. These are churches
of almost every imaginable stripe.
And they're springing up. And from a
mainstream perspective perspective,
they're quickly eroding the authority
of the, of the Church of England.
It was becoming absolutely
impossible, in fact, or at least much,
much harder to claim that there was a
single expression of religious truth to
which the English nation
could consensually subscribe.
And suddenly there are dozens and dozens
of competing expressions of religious
truth.
And so you have a,
a new proliferation of new religions
and new religious ideas, uh,
that comes about is the immediate
product of the freedom of the press.
And so it's in this decade, in fact,
that we have the first newspapers,
the printed word begins
to take on assumes, uh,
a political and the cultural importance
that it had never had before.
So the proliferation of religious texts
and the proliferation of religious sects
produced,
uh,
what was widely seen to be a potentially
anarchic political situation in the
early 1640s.
And it's in response to what was deemed
to be the chaotic condition of English
religious culture that the Presbyterian
led parliament issued in 1643.
The Licensing Act, the, the, the,
the Presbyterians needed to hold the
endless generation of dangerous religious
propaganda and uh,
and continued Mattel.
What they felt on some level was,
uh,
was the continued metastasis of,
of Protestant sects.
And this is a recurring rhetoric,
the,
this notion that there is a
cancer in the body politic.
So parliament enacts
through this legislation.
A mechanism for the state control of,
of the press books now
have to be licensed.
They have to be preapproved by the state
before they can actually be published.
And so when the controversies that
are leading up to the licensing act,
one of the authors most
frequently mentioned as
opposing especial threat to the
wellbeing of the of the English nation
is our very own, is our very own Milton.
The treatises that he had written in
favor of the right to divorce for reasons
of in compatibility,
um,
in the earlier 1640s hadn't
scandalized his contemporaries,
isn't it? Especially scandalized
dispirit and contemporaries on the left.
So meet Milton was particularly
singled out as one of them, uh,
as one of these dangerous new
voices that had to be stopped.
And in a sermon that was preached to
parliament and the August and August of
1644 a by Herbert Palmer,
um,
it's, it's Milton whose
name is cited as one of the,
as one of those figures
most dangerous to the state.
So now my guess is that maybe
not all of you, but some of you,
uh, we'll have, we'll have, uh,
heard about or perhaps actually, um,
have read snippets from a today's reading,
this amazing treatise long before you
got to it last night area politica it,
this is without question one of the
English languages most powerful and most
most browsing expressions of the freedom
of the press and actually of the, of,
of a kind of libertarian philosophy
in general. And, and, and,
and the logic,
the argumentative logic of very OPA
Jenica rests on the distinction between a
distinction between
external compulsion on the,
on the one hand and internal
discipline on the other,
an internal discipline being something,
looking something like an internalization
of the discipline and the authority of
the, uh, of, of the
monarch. So we have the,
we have the compelling official
authority of the new state licenser and,
and Milton pits that external state
power against the powers of reason and
against the powers of conscience
that of course govern.
We're seem to govern human action
from within an internalized authority.
And it's of course not just John Milton
who's authorized to determine his own
actions. Everyone according to
the logic of very open, Ritika,
everyone has the potential to assume the
inner authority of conscience and self
discipline. Everyone has potentially
a licenser within himself.
And so there's no need. There's no
logical need for a state license.
Sir. Um, it's hard. It's a,
let me, let me, uh, there,
there's a, there's a,
there's some passages in area
politica that I would be,
I would be remiss to overlook.
Um,
so I'm going to ask you to
turn to page 739 in the Hughes.
So there's and Milton's arguing that
there's no authority that can rightfully
exist outside of the conscience of the
individual and even religious truths,
which of course are the most potent
forms of knowledge that we have.
Even religious truths have to be
subjected to the final arbiter who is the
individual's conscience and the
individual's power of, of reasons.
So Milton is taking the argument.
It's at so many points in area
politica as far as it can possibly go.
This is page 739. Um, uh,
a man may be a heretic in the truth.
Milton writes,
a man may be a heretic in the truth and
if he believes things only because his
passenger says so,
or the assembly so determines
without knowing other reason,
though his belief to be true,
yet the very truthy
holds becomes his heresy.
Don't think of that though.
Is Belief be true?
Think expand in your minds
the implications, the
possible consequences of this.
Any belief, any belief is
heresy. If you haven't managed,
managed to determine
that belief for yourself.
If you haven't managed to determine
that belief on the basis of your own
conscience or through the powers of
your own faculty of reason, you can be,
you can be a heretic in the truth.
If you accept a belief.
However true that belief turns out
to be at the end of time when we,
when we enter the pearly gates and
we finally get the last word. Um,
you're a,
you're a heretic because you've accepted
that belief only because it's been
handed to you by an External Authority
and external authority like a pastor or a
bishop or a member of the
state assembly, um, or uh,
or a lecturer in the English department
for that, for that matter. Um, you,
it is your obligation. Milton argues
in this remarkable treatise, uh,
determine for yourself.
Yeah.
What will constitute truth.
All truth have to be acquired directly
by the individual. It is, it's,
it's perfectly impossible,
I think to imagine a stronger statement
than this of the authority that Milton
gives the end,
the intellectual self possession
that he ascribed to the individual.
And I think we can,
you can see why area politica has been
memorialized for centuries now as one of
the central precursors, well to a number
of things. One of them would be the, uh,
the, the, the, the, the
18th century enlightenment.
And it's subsequently seen as one of the,
uh,
one of the precursors of
the first amendment to the,
to the American constitution.
It's here,
it's here in area politica that we
find one of the first expressions
of the idea that an individual's freedom
to read and the individual's freedom to
write is more important.
It outweighs in value,
the state's right to limit
the individual's freedom to
read and the individual's
freedom to write what,
whatever danger a particular text may
pose to this date is outweighed by the
greater harm of the official elimination
of the, of the, of that text,
or by the greater harm of
the punishment of the author.
So it, in light of what
we have to concede is the,
is the extraordinary achievement of area
politica and in light of its reputation
as one of the foundational texts for the
principle of the freedom of speech. Um,
readers have been puzzled and
they've been rightly puzzled by,
by the fact that nowhere in areopagite
[inaudible] does Milton explicitly
denounce censorship?
Nelson doesn't say,
doesn't denounce censorship at all,
although it comes up. Um, in fact,
he even claims and he does this explicitly
an area politica and you might've
caught this, he even claims to be in favor
of censorship in a number of cases. Uh,
Milton's argument in this treatise is
directed exclusively at licensing and
licensing differs from censorship in
some important ways. And so let me, um,
and uh, indulge me in making
this important distinction.
We know what censorship is.
Censorship is the banning of books that
had been published and that had been
deemed by the state authorities to
be dangerous or harmful in some way.
So censorship would involve
the burning of books, uh,
the prohibition of any further additions
of those books or perhaps even the
punishment, um, by imprisonment,
say of the author or maybe the printer
or the publisher of the books. That's,
that's censorship. Utterly
straightforward. Licensing
on the other hand,
is an action that precedes censorship.
And so according to the 1643 licensing
order against which Milton is directing
this treatise area,
Politica a book has to be sent to the
licensing office for approval before,
before it can be published.
And the licensing agent reads the book
and determines whether or not to print it
at all or, or, or,
or license it to appear in print. Um, and,
and this isn't simply a distinction
without a difference. Uh,
Milton Milton places in enormous amount
of weight on this, on this distinction.
Censorship only comes into play once a
text has actually been in circulation for
a while,
only after a number of readers have
found a published text to pose a threat.
Um, only after that point can
a text actually be censored.
The book has to be tested.
It has to be tried, um,
by the public, by a reading public before
it can be censored. Um, and it's, uh,
it's censorship by consensus almost and
it's a truth that has come about. The,
the truth of whether a book should or
should not be censored is something that's
come about through the diligent effort
of a group rather than a single arbitrary
judge like those state licenser.
Milton is,
uh,
Milton devotes a lot of time in area of
Politica to making a number of attempts
to distinguish licensing from censorship.
And you can see,
I'm actually making this distinction,
but what I'm interested in here,
and I think what a lot of readers
are interested in when they,
when they approach [inaudible]
is why this treatise,
which does in fact permit
the practice of censorship,
why it can so easily be read as
an argument against censorship.
And in fact,
this treatise is often described or
maybe even most commonly described as the
western traditions greatest
argument against censorship.
Obviously there's something going on
in this text that has produced this
confusion or we could think of it as a
misreading. Um, and it, this is of some,
this is of some interest to us.
So,
so turn to the left hand column
of page 720 in the Hughes edition.
This is where Milton speaks of the
importance of censoring dangerous books.
Milton explains that the licensing order
of 1643 is ineffective [inaudible].
It's useless because,
and I'm quoting here,
this order avails nothing to suppressing
of scandalous seditious and libelist
books, which were mainly
intended to be suppressed.
Milton striking, uh, such a strange
authoritarian note here that it's easy,
it's easy,
it's easy to skip over it.
It seems unaccommodating will almost
a look at the next look at the next
paragraph.
Id nine odd,
but that ended up is of greatest concern
went in the church and the Commonwealth
to have a vigilant eye,
how books demean themselves,
how books demean themselves as well as
men and thereafter to confine in prison
and do sharpest justice
on them as malefactors.
Now we know of course,
that this is an argument for censorship
and not an argument for licensing
because the punishment of the books and
the implicit punishment of their men who
write those books occurs after
their appearance in print. And,
and Milton then goes on to explain,
and I want you to look closely at this.
Milton goes onto explain why books
need to be brought to justice,
why books need to be punished,
essentially like criminals
in this personify in the,
in Milton's personifying.
So Milton continues for books
are not absolutely dead things,
but do contain a potency of life in
them to be as active as that soul was.
Who's progeny?
They are nay.
They do preserve as in a vial the purest
efficacy and extraction of that living
intellect that bred them.
Okay, let me stop there.
The ostensible purpose of this sentence,
um,
at this point as I take it in Milton's
argument is to explain the importance of
censorship. But the, uh,
surely this sentence has an entirely
different effective on us as, as readers.
Um,
a different effect than the syntax or the
logic of this sentence may demand that
the scandalous seditious and libelous
books that need to be brought to justice
are suddenly in this remarkable sentence
or suddenly revealed to have a soul.
However,
dangerous books are in a lot of ways,
these books look like good,
good Christians. And in fact,
they're better than good Christians
because books are the purest,
the most rarefied extract of the
originary goodness of the author,
and absolutely unfollowing
perfect creation.
And, and, and it's important to understand
that clearly something very strange has
happened here.
This sentence,
which by the logic of the argument should
be demonstrating to us the importance
of being,
bringing bad books to justice
seems to be doing something else.
And, and, and in making this point,
Milton has just made us, I think, um,
almost utterly unwilling to effect this
justice that he himself has called for
which of us,
which of us would want to punish the
purest efficacy of a living intellect? It,
it,
it doesn't make sense in,
in the simplest possible terms.
You could say that Milton's sentence,
Milton's argument here in this
paragraph has gotten away from him.
And there's a sense in which you can
see this happening all the time in Aereo
politica there.
It's as if a gap has opened up a gap
between the official argument of the
treatise. And that's an argument
that permits censorship. And,
and the rhetorical
figures are the metaphors,
the Milton's elaborately
construed language,
which he uses to illustrate that argument.
And the metaphors or the
rhetorical world of the, uh,
of the treatise seems so often
to be against censorship.
And it's fairly easy to see that,
at least in this case, Milton's,
Milton's rhetoric and his imagery,
uh,
begin to undo,
begin,
begin to unravel the logic of
the argument. And it's this,
it's a process of undoing an undermining
that really eats away at the argument.
We could argue, uh, throughout
the entirety of very OPA,
Jennica and I, so I'm,
I'm willing to bet, I'm willing
to bet that some of you have had,
had noted in your reading last night
or whenever you did your reading. Um,
perhaps you actually underlined the
sentence that we've just looked like
convinced you,
underlined it perhaps because you
were convinced that this was Milton's
wonderful and libertory progressive
celebration of the absolute and viable
inviolability of the written word.
And if you did that on some level,
I think you were,
you were absolutely right.
Even though you were utterly
misconstruing the logic of the argument.
One of the most,
one of the most remarkable things about
this text is that it's invariably the
soaring,
the libertarian rhetoric that we end up
noting and that we end up remembering
that, that, that sticks with us. Um,
turn to turn to page seven,
41 in the Hughes.
This is where Milton gives us his,
his celebrated narrative of the history
of truth. And this is one of those,
uh, highly and elaborately, uh,
rhetorically ornamented passages.
So in Milton's argument against licensing,
Milton explains the importance of
the coexistence and it's very moving.
The coexistence is an
argument for diversity,
the coexistence of so many conflicting
opinions and beliefs. And, and,
and as, and as I've suggested before, he's
more conservative. Contemporaries were,
were appalled by the proliferation of
religious sects in mid 17th century,
in the mid 17th century England.
And so it would have been
perfectly reasonable for them.
He's opponents to assume that only one
set of religious beliefs could actually
represent the truth,
that there was only one possible
manifestation of divine truth. Um,
one has, one has roommates,
one has parents, um,
uh,
in our own day and age who of course
share such a belief in an absolute
singularity of, of the truth and
ones sometimes one has parents or,
or, uh, roommates who not only
believe that there is a single tooth,
but of course are themselves
in possession of it.
It's just this limited and for Milton
restrained or constrained and reductive
notion of a single truth that he
devotes a so much a very open Shitaka to
attacking.
So this is page seven 41 truth indeed
came once into the world with her divine
master and it was a perfect shape,
most glorious to look on.
But when he ascended and his
apostles after him were late asleep,
then straight arose or wicked race of
deceivers who has that story goes of the
Egyptian Typhon with his conspirators,
how they dealt with the good,
oh Cyrus took the wicked
deceivers took the virgin truth,
hued her lovely form into a pieces and
scattered them to the four winds from
that time ever since the sad friends of
truth such as Durst appear imitating the
careful search that isis made for the
mangled body of Oh Cyrus went up and down,
gathering up limb by limb
still as they could find them.
Let me, I'll, I'll stop there with this
original utterly original fable about the
fragmentation of what we think
of as, uh, as religious truth.
Milton goes out of his way is this,
is, this is, this is remarkable.
He's actually enacting and he's enacting
it rhetorically the fragmentation of
religious culture in, in
17th century England. Uh,
but one of the,
one of the most intriguing aspects of
this amazing passage is the fact that
this,
the fragmentation that
Milton is describing and on
some level even enacting is
something that he seems to
be celebrating here with the,
with the ascent of Christ,
the lovely form of the Virgin truth is
hued into a thousand pieces and scattered
to the four winds. The violence of this
action, of course we can't deny, um,
but it gets more complicated than that.
The Egyptian Goddess Isis seeks
out the mangled body of, of,
of her lover Oh Cyrus,
because of her powerful affection for
him and because of her desire presumably
to see him whole again.
There's also though I think a hint here
that part of the pleasure behind isis is
search involves this,
the process of reassembling her lover,
the process of gathering
him up limb by limb,
the act of gathering,
uh,
present participles a in general,
in area up.
Angelica being probably the
most important form of speech.
The active gathering him
may be more pleasurable,
more desirable than actually having
him fully reconstituted. And it's,
it's likewise,
I think part of our pleasure.
I'm in this crazy world of
disparate and confusing truths.
If we imagine ourselves in
the 17th century, it's part
of our pleasure to read,
to sort out and to reassemble the
various manifestations of truth.
That's, that's our common
project here. In fact, um, in,
in an English department saying the sad
friends of truth in this fable have gone
up and down,
gathering up truth limb by limb
still as they could find them.
We have not yet found them
all Lords and Commons,
nor ever shall do till her master's.
Second coming.
We have not yet found
the modelers and Commons,
nor ever shall do till her master's.
Second coming.
He shall bring together every joint
in member and shall mold them into an
immortal feature of
loveliness and perfection.
I surely these last two
sentences come as a surprise.
We have not yet found them
all nor ever shall do.
We'll never find truth in her entirety,
at least not until the second coming.
And who knows when that will be. And I
think that for Milton in this passage,
the fact that we never shall do is is
just as well because it's the labor of,
it's the Labor of reading.
It's the labor of researching.
It's the labor of assemblage rather
than the actual finished product,
uh, that, that, that motivates
and spurs the miltonic individual.
Milton Milton wants to,
Milton wants us to get,
to get us to feel the excitement as we,
uh,
as we read a passage like this though,
and the language that he uses in this
passage is itself a kind of demonstration
of the,
of the pleasure of the process
of intellectual assemblage,
intellectual coalition of
various diverse ideas as readers.
It's our duty. It's our obligation
to, to sort out and to reassemble.
We sort out, for example,
as we read this passage,
we sought out Christian
myths from Egyptian myths or
let's say we sort out from
what we've been to Milton be
Christian truth from Egyptian myths,
but the fact that they're putting on
the same plane here suggests that both
perhaps are either truths or both
perhaps or either are or both myths.
Um, and, and we sort out the
similar confusion of gender roles,
which is truly remarkable.
Um,
as we balance the masculine Christ
with the Feminine Truth with which the
Masculine Christ is identified here,
we have to balance the,
the mysteriously female isis is
searched for her lover. Oh, Cyrus.
Um, uh, there, there's, there,
there are so many entities in this
passage that seemed to be mysteriously
conjoined in some kind of
Hermaphroditic hermaphroditic unity.
Um, and we have to, uh,
imagine the relation of the female,
oh,
Cyrus with the implicitly male
readers search for his lost lover,
which is the feminine truth.
Milton's infusing this passage with
a powerful sense of, I don't know,
what can we call it? This is a
of gender nonconformity and, and,
and cultural relativity.
Christianity emerges from this
passage as just one truth out of many.
And it's almost as if we're, we're,
we're being given our choice as readers.
We're going to being given our choice
of which set of myths is the most
attractive,
the most believable.
And maybe ultimately here we're being
given a choice as to which set of myths is
the most desirable. The,
now, as I mentioned,
the official purpose of the track is
the political subject of licensing.
Milton's responding to an immediate set
of historical circumstances and he wants
to explain the usefulness,
the value,
and in fact the beauty of religious
controversy. But when you read it,
when you read an intensely a poetic,
highly ornamented passage like
the one that we've just looked at,
I think you can see why Milton was so
interested in this contemporary problem
of,
of religious diversity in the first place.
Contradictions and in consistencies and
contemporary religious society are so
much like,
or at least look so much like the
contradictions and inconsistencies that we
find in a work of literature
that we find in a poem.
And Milton's defense of controversy is,
seems in a lot of ways continually to be
slipping into something like a defense
of poetry or certainly a defense
of his own poetic practice.
One of the, one of the structural elements
that that Lens Aereo Virginica, it's,
it's a curious power is a carefully
crafted network of images that Milton has,
has, uh, has employed to
structure the thing, the end.
And I'm thinking particularly of images
describing the activity of reading. Um,
one of the,
one of the central images
here is the image of eating.
Reading is continually being
described in terms of eating and,
and digestion.
We have already encountered on
some level the importance of the,
of the figure of eating to John Milton.
You think of think of commerce,
the ladies refusal to drink of comas.
His Cup was just the f the
first of Milton's attempt to,
Milton's attempts to bring the action
of ingestion to the very center of a,
of a literary work, a paradise
lost will be filled with, with the,
the activity of eating.
And Milton devotes more than a
few lines and it's shocking, uh,
to the process whereby the heavenly
angels not only eat food but they also
digest it.
And Milton lets us know whether
we want to know or not, how they,
those angels actually excrete
the food they have taken in.
But the most central act of eating of
course in Milton's great epic is obviously
has nothing to do with angels.
It's the eating of the
forbidden fruit by Adam and eve.
And it's because this action of eating
is so absolutely central to the plot of
paradise lost were obliged to spend.
Let's spend the rest of our time here
focusing on Milton's consideration in this
treatise in the area of
[inaudible] 1644 of, of the,
of the problem that we will find
haunting paradise lost the problem of the
eating of the fruit,
the problem of God's prohibition,
God's censorship of, of
the fruit, of the tree,
of the knowledge of good and evil.
God's licensing.
We'll see Milton's a turn to page 727.
This is the left hand column.
Milton's quoting Dionysius
Alexan dryness in this passage.
And he tells us the Diane Ics Alexon
Dryness, um, wrote, read any books,
whatever that come to thy hands for thou
art sufficient both to judge a right
and to examine each matter.
And Diane I see has compares to
this command to read everything.
Read everything you possibly can to Saint
Paul's command in the epistle to the
Thessalonians,
which is prove all things hold
fast to that which is good.
And prove proof here means to test,
to try all things.
And Paul's making a claim
here for the individuals.
This is certainly how
Milton was able to read it,
a claim for the individual's capacity to
make a moral judgment after some period
of trial or after some period of of
experimentation and Milton elaborates on
this claim that we should read
and prove anything we want.
Four,
we are sufficient to judge a right.
He's he's, he's, he's moving on
here and he might have added,
Milton tells us he might
have added another remarkable
saying of the same author
to the pure,
all things are pure,
not only meets and drinks, but all kinds
of knowledge whether of good or evil,
the knowledge cannot defile nor
consequently the books if the wheel and
conscience be not defiled for books or
as meat and vines are some of goods,
some of evil substance and yet God in
that an apocryphal vision said without
exception rise Peter,
kill and eat leaving the choice
to each man's discretion.
We should be able to read whatever
you want, whatever we want,
just as we should be able to eat
whatever we want and Milton's language.
The image here is of this is it's kind
of a combined gastronomical and literary
freedom. This is the freedom
of this smorgasbord of the,
of the public libraries slash smorgasbord
or Atticus, uh, for that matter,
a place where you can, um, eat and read.
Although not on the same, actually they
don't let you, they don't let you eat, um,
around the books. You get my
point though. Um, we should,
we should be able to try all
things to prove all things, um,
and then decide whether or
not we actually like it,
whether it brings us some sort of pleasure
and this or wisdom and this array of
choices is more than just a
luxury for Milton. It's, uh,
absolutely constituent of, of, of
the ideal, of freedom of our freedom.
Because if we don't try everything,
if we don't give ourselves an opportunity
to just, to decide for ourselves,
then of course some,
well,
someone will invariably be
making those decisions for us.
So it shouldn't be,
it shouldn't be difficult to see a kind
of problem that is beginning to arise.
Uh, in Milton's text here, as
I suggested just a minute ago,
that one of the relevant stories that is
always lying behind Milton's discussion
of human choice is the story from the
book of Genesis about Adam and Eve's
choice to eat the forbidden fruit.
And so much of [inaudible]
involves Milton's bringing
together competing images
and traditions in arguments. So
he's injured, as we've already seen,
he interweaves a Christian figures with,
with pagan figures.
He positions pro censorship argument
alongside anticensorship rhetoric or
metaphor.
And there are dozens of moments in
which it's just these opposites that are
being asked to coexist in some
kind of piece, but nowhere,
nowhere in area politica do the
conflict seems so pronounced,
are so painful or make us win so much
as the tension that arises between the
genesis story of Adam and eve.
God knows why Milton feels
compelled to bring this story up.
The tension between the story of Adam
and eve and Milton's own impassioned
argument against licensing. So I've,
as I've just noted Milton quotes,
Paul's dictum that to the
pure all things are pure.
If you're a pure, not only our meat,
meat's vines, pure meets and drinks pure,
but all kinds of knowledge, whether
of good and evil and you, oh,
you just have to extend
for a little bit this,
this Pauline philosophy of freedom
to the situation of unfollowing, uh,
the unfollowing Eden of Adam and eve
to see a kind of logical trouble that
Milton is getting himself into the,
the Genesis Story of God's peremptory
prohibition of the fruit from the tree of
the knowledge of good and evil is the
strongest analogy that I can think of to
the licensers peremptory
prohibition of a book.
Uh, obviously Milton isn't able
to make this analogy explicit.
It would completely dash any logical
sense that area [inaudible] is still
retains. Um, but it's
nonetheless, I'll, I'll,
I'll always there this,
this tension,
God's forbidding of the fruit
removes from Adam and Eve.
Any capacity for choosing and deciding.
And you can see Milton worrying in area
politica about the uneasy relationship
of his,
of his own argument to this central text.
In divine scripture.
So look at page seven 28 in the Hughes.
This is the left hand column,
good and evil.
We know in the field of this world grow
up together almost inseparably and the
knowledge of good is so involved and
interwoven with the knowledge of evil and
in so many cutting resemblance is hardly
to be discerned that those confused
seeds which were imposed on psyche as
an incessant labor to coal out and Sorta
Sunder.
We're not more intermixed.
It was from out the rind of one apple
tasted that the knowledge of good and evil
is two twins cleaving together,
leaped forth into the world and perhaps
this is that doom which Adam fell into
of knowing good and evil.
That is to say of knowing good by evil.
This is, there's so many things
to say about this passage,
but one thing that I'll just throw out
now is that it's a remarkable description
of of the modern world of,
of moral uncertainty like Isis whom we
saw piecing together the body of Oh Cyrus
or like this add friends of truth,
picking up the torn limbs
of that beautiful virgin.
We are left to coal out and sort
asunder the confused seeds of,
of good and evil. Now, on
one level of this passage,
Milton's describing this modern
condition is the product of the fall.
It's,
it's too bad that we live in this world.
This is the doom which Adam fell into.
This is the fallen condition to
which we've all been consigned.
But the passage is so much
more complicated than that
because good and evil seem
to have been mixed up in
the apple before the fall.
There was good in that
forbidden fruit as well as evil.
This is that Dune which Adam fell into
of knowing good and evil. That is to say,
of knowing good by evil,
adamant the fall didn't simply come
into a knowledge primarily of of evil.
Adam,
by tasting the apple came into a knowledge
of good and he was only able to know
this good by means of the
experience of the knowledge of evil.
Um,
there are a lot of perspectives,
a discernible or extractable
from this treatise area.
Politica from which the fallen
state seems in so many ways,
maybe in every way superior
to its unfollowing,
to it's unfollowing
counterpart. Um, we will see,
we will see Milton
returning to all of these,
all of these questions in paradise lost.
And we will even see Milton place in the
mouth of Eve that the next sentence in
this passage, or at least, um, uh,
a paraphrased and of course
versified version of this sentence.
This is when Milton tells us
I cannot praise a cloistered virtue.
I cannot praise a fugitive and
cloistered virtue unexercised and,
and breathed that never Sally's
out and sees her adversary,
but slinks out of the race where that
immortal garland is to be run for not
without dust and heat.
And you'll find eve in
book nine of Paradise Lost
Voicing essentially this same
sentiment when she's
explaining to Adam why she,
why she needs to work separately. Uh, this
is the argument that really of course,
puts her at risk of Satan's
temptation and to so many readers.
It has seemed that eve is actually
quoting Milton's much earlier writing area
politica in her defense. And it has
an incredibly unsettling effect.
Evil has to be challenged.
It has to be confronted,
it has to be tasted before
it can be conquered. It,
it can't simply be avoided.
This is,
this is eaves and area
of political argument.
We will never be virtuous simply
because we've cloistered ourselves or
segregated ourselves from any temptation.
Virtue is to be fought for,
um,
raced for not without Dustin heat.
So let me conclude.
Let me conclude the lecture by,
by saying that it's a startling experience
and I hope you feel some of the,
some of their surprise moving
from area Politica, which, uh,
has to be Milton's most important
and consequential work in prose.
Moving from that to paradise lost,
which is of course Milton's
most important work of poetry.
And we'll be doing this in one in one
week. And the disjunction between these,
between the two works,
this disjunction,
at least with respect to their
treatment of the fall, um,
should dramatize the nature or just
the enormity of a lot of the conceptual
problems and conflicts that Milton is,
is,
is tackling here as a faithful
Christian. Of course. And I, I'm,
I'm not going to try to deny
this. Um, as a faithful Christian,
Milton believes that the fall is only
to be lamented and that Adam and eve
should not have eaten the apple.
And as a believing Christian,
Milton believes that the omnipotent
God has had every right to license to
prohibit that apple. But
it's a measure. It's,
and we have, it's a measure
that we have to take seriously.
It's a measure of Milton's ambition
and his intellectual courage that,
that,
that enables him to set out to justify
a God who can inflict upon his creatures
such a seemingly Arbitrary Act,
act of licensing. The, and,
and the extent to which Milton and
succeeds and justifying such a God in
paradise lost will be.
Of course,
one of the questions that we
will be exploring over the next,
over the next couple of weeks,
so you will read for Wednesday's class,
uh,
the first two books of paradise lost.